this is ridiculous did you have a hole
in that or what happened I'm gonna clean
that up like really I didn't do that you
know this is my goddamn home right you
live in the show hello today we're gonna
talk to you about the election of 1800
Thomas Jefferson and John Adams they
were founding fathers of America and
they were also the best of friends Adams
like the Constitution you can kind of
bend that how you need to bend it we can
kind of work with this Jefferson was
always like Constitution is the
Constitution can with that but they
loved each other until I became
president and immediately they started
butting heads John Adams was like it's
illegal to talk any about the president
of the United States and if you disagree
with the federal government you and
Jefferson was like well this is tyranny
that's a violation of little something
called freedom of speech it all really
reaches its head on the election of 1800
where these two lifelong friends were
pitted against each other Adams like if
you elect Thomas Jefferson here's what
you're gonna get
murder all the time everybody's gonna be
murdering each other
incest your wives will lose their virtue
having sex with a lot of dudes
willy-nilly so Jefferson starts talking
a lot of about John Adams we're talking
about guys who like created this country
they were really like a bunch of eighth
graders he was like you know what Adams
has prostitutes shipped in from overseas
that he bangs all the time I'm just
gonna just gonna tell you that right now
I'm I feel like I keep seeing spit
flying from you know I'm feeling it
getting a lot of you're seeing it yeah
it's good I'm gonna splash some so
Jefferson went to the newspapers he says
I want to tell you this John Adams is a
hermaphrodite he's got both man and
woman's sex organs this is like a
published statement from Thomas
Jefferson Adams was like okay fine you
want to go that route that's when got
really dirty Adams says oh by the way if
you were thinking about voting for
Jefferson you shouldn't
because he's dead it's a pretty good
campaign it's a very good boat for me
I'm alive yeah even if you disagree with
everything I say at the very least I'm
alive would you rather be accused of
having a penis and a vagina or being
dead I think being alive with the band's
own vagina would be an amazing
experience and you're alive
Jefferson calls upon a hatchet man James
Callender to publish newspaper articles
about Adams Adams wasn't gonna say yeah
oh yeah the war with the French that's
what was published in the newspapers and
it's a lie it's not true at all America
was like I don't want to go to war with
the French that sounds terrible and they
elect Jefferson into office
Jefferson wins Adams is like you want to
go with this loser fun but before I
leave I'm going to appoint all of these
people who violently oppose everything
Jefferson stands for and then he's like
I hope you like all this ass so cut to
four years down the line and Jefferson's
daughter dies and Abigail Adams it's
like look I know we've had our
differences with Jefferson but I should
pop him off a letter she's like look I'm
really really sorry about your daughter
and it sucks that she is dead Jefferson
gets this letter and he's like I I want
to thank you so much for being so
considerate about the death of my
daughter but while I've got your
attention I also want to tell you you
and your husband for being such assets
who do my presidency that's how I mature
these great men of American history work
he can't even like just like this should
have been two separate letters she's
like John you know what we're done with
Thomas Jefferson he's an ass I tried to
make it work with this guy but but yeah
so these two don't speak for a decade
eventually Benjamin Rush who was another
founding father was like look John Adams
Johnny I love you too guys why aren't
you speaking anymore
why can't we all be friends like we used
to back in those glory days those 1776
days that were so magical John Adams was
like look I love Tommy jeff's I'm a big
fan I'll pop him off a letter it's very
general it's like hey how you doing
I'm yeah I miss you I hope you're
alright how's things going
Jefferson gets the letter he's like
Adams Johnny Ads
good to hear from you buddy it's been 10
years how's life and then the letters
start flowing and before you know it
they start to connect on certain things
it start to connect on I'm a little
concerned about slavery Thomas Jefferson
was like I'm anti-slavery but I do have
hundreds place was it what am I talking
about you got it's weird how quickly
alcohol makes you not realize what you
said it all so by the end of their life
these two have exchanged a hundred and
fifty eight letters and they're best
friends again then it's 1826 John Adams
is on his deathbed and his last words
are independents forever and also Thomas
Jefferson survives because that guy's
been awesome little did he know that
just a few hours prior miles and miles
away Thomas Jefferson had also died that
day was July 4th the 50th anniversary of
the signing of the Declaration of
Independence which is crazy that's true
friendship
true friendship Cheers it's a friendship
you're my best friend we barely know
each other
ok that's right
[Music]